yesterday i was having a call with uh
uh a penguin we're launching uh the next
business book and you know how you're
talking to publishers and you're going
through a book title like well you know
we have to talk about the book title is
and uh a part of yesterday's
conversation was i said the most
important question to ask is who do you
want to be in life
what do you mean i said listen
you don't have to be bezos
basers wanted to be bezos you don't have
to be musk you don't have to be a
millionaire but who do you want to be in
life the moment you know who you want to
be in life go solve for that
what's not healthy is if you chose to
live a regular life and you're envious
of somebody else that chose to live a
bigger life
the life of a bigger life isn't a better
life right it's not an attractive life
a lot of people only see what happens 20
30 years later nobody wants to see what
happened those five 10 15 years while
they were not there at any of the events
it's called the iceberg it sucks
it sucks so guess how many people want
to go through the 10 15 20 year period
not many man
it is horrible
it's tough it's scary costs marriages
relationship family time fun party and
all that stuff this whole concept of
winning at a higher level sucks now
if somebody says well i don't want to go
through it no one should judge them
no problem you're right you can go and
contribute at any levels that you want
but the question i ask you is why are
those people in the situation they're in
what policy caused them to be in the
situation they're in and who created
those policies yeah
that's the problem yeah okay so if we
keep printing the money and throwing
money to poor and then wondering i'm
against that yeah you're against it i'm
gonna set it aside against that
okay you're against welfare yeah because
they make the working class support the
poor i hate that so how do so how do we
so how do we lift up the middle class
what's your way of lifting up the
momentum that is the that's that's the
question i'm curious so each tier needs
different things you know like this so
the top tier like they need respect what
do cops need from us right now big time
respect they freaking need our respect
because they're out there getting shot
and killed and they can't do their jobs
and the criminals aren't scared of them
anymore you know this is a job that
every american relies on and the elites
sit there and they smear people they
smear these people who are out there
giving their lives to defend them it
makes me crazy we're on the same page
right um union um
high skilled trades these are great jobs
what do they need they need our respect
they need the next generation of people
who are good with their hands and
intelligent and smart to have a pathway
to that vocational schools we don't have
any vocational schools the idea that
this is a respectable job so that kids
who are coming from you know
who are not good at school maybe you
know that they have access to that
version of the american group so the top
tier really means very little right they
don't need anything from us they don't
need anything from the government that's
for sure right you're saying the top
tier of the working class yes
exactly so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]